it's a true work of art and we don't see
a lot of films that
live up to you know the words true work
of art
these days what are your 10 favorite
movies
my 10 favorite movies is an impossible
question
and i would be like a
i i would probably short circuit i will
tell you what one of my all-time
favorite independent films is
which is the original slacker directed
by richard linklater
that movie completely breaks your
standard mold
of a traditional storytelling you know
with
three-act structure it's it's a day in
the life of austin texas
where we meet all types of people in all
walks of life
and they kind of have intersecting lives
each
story kind of crosses over into the next
and it's beautiful and absolutely sweet
and inspiring
that would be in my top 10 list
another film would be 2001
a space odyssey directed by stanley
kubrick is
probably for me a perfect film
in the sense that uh i saw it when i was
five years old as a kid
and it blew my mind and
i i probably watch it every few weeks
and by that i mean i uh keep it on in
the background while i'm working on
on other things but 2001 a space odyssey
is so inspiring
is so um beautiful and then
i mean it's it's a it's a true work of
art
and we don't see a lot of films that
live up to
you know the words true work of art
these days
and i i tend to notice something new
about it every time i see it
there's something fascinating about that
film
um and and just the artistry the the
cinematography the
the way the way that these special
effects in that film
stand up to today there was never a
special edition
of of 2001 a space odyssey
although pro tip if you
if you get the film on itunes
they will allow you to watch the film
with the original 1968 theatrical sound
mix
which i strongly recommend but that film
inspires me it it it just it it i
i just kind of turn inward whenever i
watch that film and think about
life and death and the cosmos and the
unknown and all the
unanswerable questions that we you know
that religion attempts to to answer for
us
that are truly unanswerable only perhaps
by faith
and that that film asks those questions
without providing an answer which i
think is um
terrifying so i love that movie
uh the original star wars also has to be
on that list
um along with the empire strikes back
because
the time that they were made when you go
back to filmmaking in the 1970s
uh those movies were dark
another favorite i would add to the list
see i'm actually going to get to the
list
um is taxi driver by martin scossesi um
and when you look at the films that were
being made at the time in the 1970s
they were very dark the themes were you
know this is a post-nixon era
when you know really
it was it was it was in in the shadow
of all the you know cultural cultural
upheaval of the 1960s
and the 70s were the hangover from that
and still
films were very dark um even in the
realm of
you know science fiction and george
lucas set out to
to kind of flip that and say i'm gonna
make a fairy tale for kids because there
are no
heroes in movies today i mean at least
that's what he thought in the early 70s
when he first began
his journey of writing the original star
wars
film so that one just stands out
and when i say the original star wars
the original cut
that was theatrical theatrically
released on may 25th 1977
which i saw in a theater just a few days
later that original cut is just
remarkable
and famously george lucas did continue
to cut even after it was only released
on about what
a dozen screens initially and the empire
strikes back just sort of
flipped that
interestingly when george lucas set
about
working on the story for the empire
strikes back
and determined that his heavy which was
considered to be you know in the initial
writing of star wars a small role
darth vader he considered i'm going to
make this
the main hero's father and present
um a dilemma that is you know in order
to
you know defeat the evil empire i have
to kill my own father
and he actually consulted a child
psychologist
to learn how this might affect
children how the idea of this might
affect children you know
we live in a time now where pop culture
is consumed so quickly
that a new disney plus series episode
will come out on a wednesday
and we've dissected every part of it
found every easter egg
and discussed it to death within 24
hours of its airing
and the same goes with the film it opens
on a thursday night
friday and by monday
it's it's all been it's all been
discussed um
at the time that that films opened when
i was a kid and seeing movies
it was a discussion that lasted for
for some of these films years um
logan's run i would add to that list
only as a
i don't really have a guilty pleasure
i'm just gonna say logan's run
um because i i like the ideas espoused
in that film yes it's shot in a shopping
mall in dallas
with futuristic escalators and cheesy
special effects that do not hold up
uh but the performance by michael york
and jenny agather
is just transcends
the poor special effects
um also an amazing score but
that film had a profound effect on me as
a kid
uh and and i i just
love the ideas that was you know there's
there's a little bit of brave new world
in that um in logan's run kind of
borrows from that
and uh the theatrical version of that
movie
with michael york is very different than
the novel
uh by william f nolan which i read as a
third grader and it really scarred me
because it's such a different
the book and the movie are so vastly
different
um you know i
a top 10 list for me is just like so
difficult to put together
i can talk about favorite films and
those kind of
change with um
change with you know what my current
thinking is about things
um so this is an impossible question
which is what i'm happy you're asking
it's really impossible for me
for me to to respond to that with a top
um but but these are some of my
favorites and the and the reasons they
and they they resonate for me to today
now if boyhood had come out when you
were a child
do you think that would replace slacker
is there something nostalgic about some
of the like
because you know for me i love boyhood
uh it's not that i didn't like slacker
but
i thought boyhood was a masterpiece so
do you think you would have
that would have been your your one of
your top ten yeah that's interesting
point
um i do think that many of the films
from uh that are
in my top list or movies that i saw at
a younger age they because they left
such a profound
impression you know films like
apocalypse now um i think
and and i would also say i would add to
that list uh uh pink flamingos
john waters i saw that film when i was
16 years old
uh i i i got a car not because i cared
about
girls i got a car because i wanted to go
to movies
so when i went to this rep this
repertory theater
did a john waters tribute and i saw pink
flamingos and it was shocking to me i
couldn't believe that people that
that you know structurally speaking i
mean yeah i guess it follows
3x structure structure but there's so
many shocking elements
in that film you know in addition to
uh you know glenn milstead the the drag
queen divine
who is you know uh probably one of the
greatest drag queens in cinematic
history
if that could be said um but that movie
had
a huge effect on me when i was 16 and
then i just like sort of went down
a rabbit hole i was fortunate enough to
work at a video store
that had some of his other films i
female trouble might be
a personal uh favorite because it's um
it involves uh christmas day
and cha cha heels which i thought was so
weird
i mean john waters kind of opened my
world up to like movies don't have to be
this way they don't have to be
hollywood films so i would say
everything from like slacker being
this small indie movie made by this kid
richard linklater in austin texas
you know that you know just huge effect
on me to
like john waters who's been a true
independent his entire career too
truthfully george lucas is an
independent filmmaker
you know i mean yes he found funding in
hollywood
but his company lucasfilm was not
located
in los angeles he relocated to marin
county in northern california
specifically to get away from hollywood
i don't blame him um but i would say
that if there's if there's a thread
uh that all the films that had an effect
on me is they're all by
very independent minded voices
and my fear with modern hollywood as it
becomes more corporatized
is that those voices will be lost
and the ability to
express oneself in
through cinema because it's so expensive
that those voices will be lost and and
that's what i have a real
concern with um and
and and i see where the 70s filmmaking
in hollywood was
very independently driven with this
young
group of filmmakers everyone from
spielberg to you know lucas and scorsese
and
coppola among others young at the time
um
they were these new mavericks in
hollywood uh and
truly had independent voices i don't
know if we'll see an era like that again
and it's it's disheartening to me and
and
i i hope that there is some push to
support these independent filmmakers i
do whatever i can
with my my own outlet film threat you
know we champion
these small filmmakers but they just
don't get the support
from the mass media like whatever the
latest disney marvel pixar star wars
thing is which tends to consume
all of the consume the conversation of
film for that week
and um so that's kind of been my
kind of my life's work through film
thread is just to elevate these smaller
movies
i just wonder if we'll see that same era
again
you